the jurogan experience
so how does that work like who
so if a person like you is a national
security advisor like in a general
where who who comes to you with these
ideas and plans
well it's your job to kind of convene
the you know the the president's cabinet
right the principal's committee of the
national security council and and you
know joe i you know i i write about this
in in the book i i
i walked into that office really
unexpectedly obviously right you know i
i've been walking down walnut street in
philadelphia pennsylvania on my way to a
think tank my job at the time was
designed to design the future army so
i'm an active duty lieutenant general
and i was gonna brief this think tank
community get their thoughts on a study
that we had commissioned
uh almost a two year long study on
russia's annexation of crimea and
invasion of ukraine and russian new
generation warfare and what it meant
right for developing the future army and
the future military
and my phone rings and it's a partially
blocked number from you know from the
you know from the from the white house
oh boy and they say hey uh hey the
president would like you to interview
for the job national security adviser
mar-a-lago it says partially so it just
says 202 which is 202. that's it that's
it yeah but that's something like batman
[ __ ] so that's
that's why that's why i answered it
typically i wouldn't answer my phone on
the way to the meeting but maybe i had
to answer this one so so uh
you know it came that came out of the
blue and so that was a friday right and
sunday i'm interviewing for the job wow
he hires me on you know president's day
monday
i fly back to washington right you know
on on everything you interviewed at
mar-a-lago at moral so you're having
like shrimp cocktails hey i didn't know
how to get food there man so what so
after after the first interview right
they said hey the president would
probably like to talk to you again so i
i stayed they just kept me there for the
rest of the day i went into the military
aids office you know because i know
they'll know those guys and we're on the
military so i'm hanging out in their
office i'm doing emails for my regular
job and you know of course calling my
wife and and calling katie and talking
to her about it
and and there's there's no food i don't
know how to get food so i ate everything
that those guys had i ate their
pistachio nuts man i i left my note hey
sorry guys i'll have to replenish your
supplements you can't ask trump hey
buddy
where's the man get a statement i
probably could have gotten some meatloaf
or something i'm sure i'm sure i could
have
missed opportunity but but so so anyway
that one day i fly back to dc and uh i
didn't even live in dc so they had these
osprey aircraft waiting to take me back
to my house in in in tidewater virginia
i packed a bag and i started on tuesday
man i mean so so it was quick but i had
this you know i had this great gift that
the army gave me which is the
opportunity to study history you know
and
and so i walk into to me mcgeorge
bundy's office the guy who was national
security advisor when vietnam became an
american war and i wrote a book called
dereliction of duty about how why
vietnam became an american war and
identified
all the deficiencies in the
decision-making policy-making process
right in in washington so
i resolved at least okay i'm not gonna
make the same mistakes right and and so
those one of those mistakes or what
you're alluding to is
you know they they didn't spend enough
time thinking about the nature of the
problem right they didn't frame out the
problem use kind of design thinking to
think about it right so when i came into
the job you know we we uh
we established you know what i thought
were the the top 16
challenges to our security and
prosperity in the world right and and
then we organized a framing effort
around those and we put together a
meeting called a principal small group
framing session where the president's
cabinet right the secretary of state and
defense and the all the heads of the
intelligence community um you know come
together
to to to really approve how we've
described the problem associated with
chinese communist party aggression with
russian aggression with iran and iran's
pursuit of a nuclear weapon with north
korea and north korea's nuclear prop
program and and and other threats from
north korea
is threats that are that are occurring
more frequently and are more
consequential in cyberspace for example
and and so i as i came into the job i
was grateful for the opportunity to
study it from a historical perspective
anyway well you're you're famously
non-partisan
you're you're a guy who didn't even vote
while you were in active duty you you
decided a long time ago that that was
the best course of action to stay
completely unbiased and to concentrate
entirely on the goals and objectives of
the military right right so
when you're with a guy like trump
you're going to be associated
politically like if you're a part of the
trump administration it's like right
you're immediately associated with trump
and then with uh all the good and the
bad that comes with that so was that a
shock to the system like what was that
like to go from you get this phone call
from this weird number all of a sudden
you're in mar-a-lago trying to find some
food
and then uh you're the national security
advisor well you know you know uh i
really think it was a benefit to stay on
active duty you know and and and i i
really think that i mean i i know like
you do i when i look at the polarization
our society today this partisan politics
i think okay why can't we just talk
about what we can agree on so i think in
the area of foreign policy that ought to
be an area where we could agree like who
wants iran to have a nuclear weapon
right who wants to only hereditary
communist dictatorship in the world you
know the kim family regime of north
korea to have the most destructive
weapons on earth who wants russia to
intimidate all the countries on his
periphery develop destabilizing nuclear
weapons try to coerce us like they're
doing now who wants china to eat our
lunch economically okay let's talk about
that across partisan lines right you
shouldn't be partisan issues so i think
donald trump was the fifth the fifth
commander-in-chief i served in uniform
right when i took the oath of office at
west point
with the oath at west point as a you
know as a pleb there you know in in uh
gosh the summer of 1980 right reagan was
president right so
it didn't matter to me who the
commander-in-chief was i was going to do
my best to to fulfill my oath which was
to to support and defend the
constitution against all enemies foreign
and domestic right and to bear true
faith and lead us to the same you know
and and i felt like i could serve trump
well by
you know by helping him determine his
agenda he's the guy that got elected
right and then and then once he made
decisions to help orchestrate the
sensible implementation of his decisions
and that's that's the job i took on
you